[Music]
we start with the news on the las vegas
strip
another overnight fight and shooting in
the resort corridor happened just before
one o'clock this morning according to
metro police
outside planet hollywood now this is a
live look at the scene this happened as
i mentioned at about one o'clock it's
been four hours since then and the scene
is completely clear now
metro police say two men got into a
fight on the pedestrian bridge and
during the fight
one of the men involved fired a shot
investigators say nobody was injured
the two men involved were immediately
arrested a third though
took off and was caught a couple of
hours later we'll continue to follow
this
throughout the morning last monday we
covered another
shooting near planet hollywood now in
that case metro police say one
man was shot and wounded during a fight
outside the miracle mile shops
there have been several high profile
fights and shootings on the strip
in recent weeks metro police launched an
effort to try and flood tourist areas
with more
officers and to try and keep the peace